Speaker 1: Hey, this is something very
interesting. I want to be really careful about
what I say because I want to protect people's
privacy here. A Fox News executive has leaked
some documents to me about Fox News's vaccine
policy and vaccine reporting requirements.
And Fox News is really, really strict. Even
though on air, Fox News has made a huge deal
out of attacking vaccine requirements and
protocols and mandates or whatever you call them.
And even though Fox hosts on air have said, We
don't have a mandate here, we have a protocol,
even though it's a stricter protocol than the one
outlined by Joe Biden. They behind the scenes are
really taking this seriously, and Fox News
has an insanely high vaccination rate. Why?
Because vaccine requirements work, as we've said
before. So we've gone at it. We've been asked by
this Fox executive who's sick of what's
going on there. This is stunning stuff.
We've been asked by them to remove any personally
identifying information, which I have done. OK,
so let's look at this information first. I got
an email today from this Fox executive who said,
David, I joined today. Join Pacman dot com. I am a
long time Fox employee. I am in management at Fox,
and I am disgusted with the lies and
misinformation. Honestly, Hannity and
especially Tucker, deserve a kick in the nuts. You
can say nuts, that's what that word is allowed.
They make me sick. The lies that
they are allowed to spread are sick.
My political and philosophical views pretty
much match up with yours to a tee. I've been
listening for about three to four months. I used
to not care about politics, but the Trump years in
the pandemic made me a hardcore resister of Trump.
MAGA racism lies COVID and vaccine misinformation
of Fox make me really angry. If I could afford
to lose my job, I would say something, but they
pay me well and the insurance is excellent. Fox
took COVID seriously. I worked on site through
the pandemic. They paid all my insurance premiums
for the entire pandemic. See below. Please don't
use my name or email, but feel free to contact
me if you wish. I would call your voicemail,
but I don't want anyone to recognize my voice.
I will help if I can. I hate what Fox has done
and what they have allowed to happen with Tucker
and his Patriot purge. Keep up the good work
and reach out to me if you like. You can talk
about this if you like, keep my name out of it,
please. Also my email address. Thanks for what you
do. Keep up the fight, my friend regards Seabelo
Fox mentions insurance premiums below and then
a screenshot of the COVID policy. This is very
interesting. This is someone in fox management.
Very, very interesting. So check out some of
the things that they sent to me, and these are
fascinating COVID policy email. Check this out, as
we have said as we have through the pandemic, Fox
is following the guidance and policies of the CDC,
as well as state and local jurisdictions with
mask wearing and social distancing requirements
for fully vaccinated individuals being lifted
in nearly all the areas where we operate.
Fox has made several important updates to
our COVID protocols, as described below,
for us to provide the most flexibility to our
employees. We strongly encourage everyone who
has been fully vaccinated to upload vaccination
information into work day. Instructions for how
to do that. So they have a not only a vaccine, a
protocol, they have a vaccine reporting protocol.
What about HIPA? What about hippo? What about
rhino and giraffe? And all of these things that
are supposedly being violated? Per the Fox hosts,
as they say on air, Well, Fox is doing it. Fox
is saying, you've got to upload the proof, my
friends fully vax OK, the new policies effective
immediately are as follows fully vaccinated
employees who have uploaded status into work day.
And it has been verified by H.R., are not required
to wear a mask or socially distance when at work,
employees are considered fully vaccinated two
weeks after their second dose in a two dose series
or two weeks after a single dose. However, keep in
mind, some work sites off party and third parties
have different requirements. OK. Fully vaccinated
individuals who have entered their vaccination
info into work day and it has been verified by
H.R. will be provided a fox clear pass. Oh my god,
is that? Is that like a star of David,
per those protesters who were putting the
yellow stars on them saying This is what
it is when you have to prove your status?
Well, Fox is doing it, folks. Fox is doing
it. You will have to. And it goes on to say
you have to do a screening process each day
that you go to work. Each day you go to work.
All right. Unvaccinated employees or people
who simply have not provided their vaccination
info are going to have to continue to complete
the daily screening note. Employees who may be
fully vaccinated but who have not entered their
info will be considered unvaccinated. So you not
only have to be vaccinated, but you have to
prove your vaccination, which many of these
anti requirement anti mandate anti protocol
people, including on Fox's airwaves, are against
because it is medical apartheid. It's OK. You guys
remember all the things they said. Here's another
fascinating message. This was an email from the
Office of Kevin Lord Dear colleagues following our
request for employees to upload their vaccination
status in our secure system. We are pleased to
share more than 90 percent of our full time
employees reported they are fully vaccinated.
Wow, it worked. This is important information
as we continue to implement phased return to
office timing and procedures. Soon, we will
introduce another health and safety measure.
Daily COVID testing stricter than Biden's
proposal for the small group of employees not
vaccinated or who have not provided vaccination
status. So again, on air, what Biden is doing is
terrible behind the scenes, even stricter, even
stricter. Here's one more, which is fascinating.
On June 22nd, 2021, FDA issued an email
for new COVID protocols. As you know,
we have been following the guidance of the CDC,
etc. However, to optimize our efforts to maintain
a safe workplace, we strongly encourage everyone
who has been fully vaccinated to upload vaccine
info to Workday attached our instructions.
Additionally, you will need to provide H.R. with
a copy or photo of your COVID vaccination record
card for verification. Fully vaccinated employees
who entered the information into work, they will
get a fox clear pass permanent green screen,
which you must show to security every day.
Unvaccinated employees are those who don't
get the Fox Clear Pass, must continue to do a
daily screening as required, must continue to
wear a face mask and continue to social distance
as an employer. Fox News is taking this very
seriously. You wouldn't know it from watching the
segments on air in the morning on Fox and Friends
midday with people like Bill Hemmer and others
Dana Perino, whoever at night watching Laura
Ingraham and Tucker and Hannity. But behind
the scenes, it is one of the strictest policies
we've seen. Thank you to that Fox News management
individual who has leaked these documents to us.
We're going to go out of our way to protect their
privacy, but understand that what you were seeing
on air does not even come close to matching
what's happening behind the scenes. Find me
on Twitter at De Packman. We're going to take
a quick break and be back right after this.